réserve un présenter un tout nouveau
clavier c'est le Black Widow V4 pro
alors il est vachement cool pourquoi
parce que vous avez ici une toute petite
molette qu'on peut venir assigner
personnalisée on appuie on change de
mode elle change de couleur c'est
pratique vous avez en plus huit boutons
macro vous en avez 5 on peut venir
personnaliser et vous en avez également
trois conscience ou le doigt mais qu'on
va pas réellement qui sont planqués
juste ici sans oublier une petite
molette en aluminium qui est très court
qu'on peut venir totalement
personnaliser des touches médias play
pose avant arrière et CSA donc ça c'est
une toute nouvelle expérience tout
nouveau clavier qui coûte 269 euros 99
chez Razer c'est le Black Widow V4 pro
expérience avec Romain bien évidemment
on peut venir personnaliser comme on le
souhaite repose poignet simili cuir je
l'aime bien je trouve pratique vous
venez brancher en plus deux prises en
usb-c vous avez de l'USB à sur le côté
trouve très très chouette je sais pas ce
que vous en pensez est-ce que vous aimez
ce produit est-ce que vous aimez
l'écosystème raison et bien évidemment
vous pouvez mettre du Philips ou d'une
Anne olive pour avoir une maison
totalement personnalisée un écosystème
complet perso je trouve ça vachement
chouette dites-moi ce que vous en pensez
dans les commentaires